[Music]
hello and welcome to this video which is
about Kings Indian setups the Kings
Indian setup involves d6 and g6 um most
of the time black also plays Knight f6
but they sometimes delay this move the
defining museum are those 2 for this
chapter the main move order that you
would encounter by players who want the
Kings in Ian's will be the following is
to show what our main line is going to
be they were mostly play like this and
of course we played g3 and continued to
complete our Castle now here they go d6
that is the defining position of the
Kings Indian after which white in the
majority of cases plays the more c4 form
a main line fianchetto Kings Indian
however wanted to um paint us however
I'm not recommending this approach but
rather the must be free for a double of
him keto the system has served me well
over the years and many friends and
teammates of mine and I'm very happy to
recommend it to you because I believe
that it will screw up very heavily just
as it always has for me and my friends
so this is something that I'm really
happy to recommend now um I want to
explain one particular thing about the
Kings in iam many kings Indian players
when they choose this opening they have
um scenarios in mind like the following
I'm just going to put your moves
this is the so-called classical Kings
Indian and what they often are after is
something like this where you have a
typical
situation of King side attack with h5g
for you can do bring the rook over and
so on and white is going to play on the
Queen side so it's a kind of who comes
first wins scenario where black is
hacking away at the King this is often
what King's Indian players have in mind
they have a rather aggressive and
ambitious mindset this is something to
really appreciate and think of because
if you look for your line against the
Kings inian it is not a bad idea to
maybe not give them their dream scenario
even though you can argue with some
justification that a line like this
could be good for white one related line
not this in particular it still gives
black what they wanted and with our
setup this is not happening at all
because we have a very safe King we will
fianchetto of course and there is just
nothing like this quite often in fact
the center is rather opened with D takes
e5 or other trades in the middle of the
board so that it is not this kind of
yeah who comes first wins scenario this
is an important psychological
considerations I don't really see many
kings in young players like to play
against the system that I'm going to
show to you first of all as mentioned
most often they play Knight f6 g6 later
d6 but this is not the only way to get
to such a setup you can also start of
course with g6 or d6 p.m. so we go
neither three Bishop g7 g 3 d6 this is
something that you can also get by Kings
Indian players that um is something that
will happen to you quite often if they
know that you are going to play the b3
system in the main move autumn because
this is often a system that people
dislike to play against and um this
often leads to them playing a quicker g6
based setup and try to discourage the b3
setups by keeping the diagonal open so
here we are going to play Bishop to g2
and now of course 9f
six would transpose into a mainline
position if they want to avoid that he
they usually play the move 97 and then
he 5 1 e 5 immediately let's have a
quick look there if they play e5
immediately and there are players who
play those moves basically no matter
what as White has done and then we
happily go into this scenario there are
many openings that feature this early
Queen trade and in fact some of them
don't really promise all that much for
white this is not one of those yeah I
think white is quite quite nicely quite
nicely better an important thing to
consider here is the next move we should
play Knight to c3 it is not advisable
play a pawn to c4 as you often see in
deform openings at the poorness on c4
it is almost a general rule that after a
trade here on the D file you should not
actually put a pawn on the c4 because
quite often this will be a much better
place for peace a knight for example
would be great there we will see more of
that later
now after Knight c3 black usually play
something like c6 we castle and they
play f6 this is very common f6 to get
the knight organized him and stabilize
the pawn yeah I recommend this is not
the only good move honestly but I
recommend I think a move that is going
to be good for Y that is the move Knight
to e1 um I like this idea we get f4 in
and often Knight 23 so that black has a
hard time to keep the pawn on e5 if you
will most likely take and this was going
to be to our advantage
note that there can still be attacking
ideas even though the Queen's are traded
if you look at the King it can be rather
vulnerable so the early 5 p.m. is
dubious due to the trade and mostly if
it has come to the
vision and they don't want to transpose
it irregular Kings Indian they were
playing Knight to d7 we Castle as we
usually do and now e5 yeah that is a way
to keep it outside of trans positions b5
now we again take we have we don't have
a pawn on c4 and then it's always a
little bit of an argument in favor of
trading because this isn't square for
the knight we see that pretty quickly
yep addy take c5 is by far the most
popular move but sometimes this this can
happen but I want to show one idea so
takes takes Knight c3 it's not there to
play E for honor this is not like a
position where only one move is good the
idea that I wanted to show you is that
like after night is 7f or Bishop g7 that
this is a strong move
we intend to play 95 and Queen d2 and
black is yeah somewhat are pressed to
find a good solution
quite often something like h6 will be
played after which we happily return
later gained a temper with Queen Queen
to d2 so here we are going to be better
one idea that we will also see in future
lines IAM is to put a knight on to d5
which will be always annoying for black
um
this caption is rather rare yeah with
the with the piece they usually take
with the on only five and again
don't play C form but rather develop the
knight um
now the black has tried a knight to have
six and nine to seven we can have you
should have a look at both um let's say
Knight to e7 first yeah my it has more
than one good move but there is one that
is particularly strong and I was quite
impressed by this that is the move Queen
to d3 the idea is that after coming rook
g1 let's say castles it's pretty obvious
route e1 that now we actually in some
lines threaten to play Bishop h3
and this is going to be rather bad if it
it's we just attack the night and it
cannot move because that would lose lots
of material so black is really in some
trouble he has to do something like this
after which we gain a tempo weeny 8 bit
ugly but that's what it is
and now Queen to u3 is a good idea
threatening Knight to d5 so this whole
line is rather rarely seen but this is
an impressively strong move quickly
trying to play on the D file and get
this Bishop a3 into the position so a
nice idea against 97 most of the time
they will play Knight to f6 though um
and now we see what I mentioned perform
you should never put a pawn to c4
because a knight will be strong there so
92 assaults and now a 4 this is a bit
more quite a bit more precise than
Knight c4 if you do that immediately
Knight b6 is going to be a possibility
for black so don't do that
but rather prepare it with a 4 now if
they play rook e8 for example we play
five and now I'm told that this open
diagonal is also a huge point a6 is a
threat and this is a bit awkward now
they probably have to play a six and
then we play 9 c4 and this is already
pretty nice pressure for white in more
than one way actually have black now has
to decide how to develop the Queen side
it's not easy here I am with the night
here
[Music]